[Musica]
il giunto il momento di vendere trovarti
milia che era facile per te e te e
sentite anche voi questi rumori non mi
dire te sono ancora i passi al piano di
sopra
[Musica]
chi evita le sei tu
vitale 6 tu perchè non rispondi
non c'è nessuno da te vitale sei tu
perchè non rispondi meglio trovare un
nascondiglio allo svelto nascondiamoci
sotto il letto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che sto facendo
ve ne andate per fortuna possiamo uscire
fuori dal letto
guardate ha lasciato qualcosa questa
storia diversa da quella che ho trovato
dentro una scatola ma quella che ha
trovato dentro la scatola non c'è più
l'ha sostituita con questa è molto più
piccola che cosa vorrà dire sì bella e
affascinante questa nuova sfera wi fi
nipote di toccarla vita si sta facendo e
chi deve spiegare una cosa ti ricordi la
scorsa sfera che mi ha fatto spuntare
queste ali si me la ricordo eccome
beh è entrato qualcuno è rubata e in
cambio ha lasciato questa sfera cosa è
chi è entrato a cambiarla
io sto io mi sono nascosta sotto al
letto sotto al letto e detenuto che era
nuova sfera a me sembra una semplice
sfera di cristallo
l'unica differenza con l'altra e che è
più piccola vero si è fatto è più
piccola è strana però penso che ci sia
niente che non va con questa sfera tu
credi che ci sia qualcosa che non va
pensi che ci sia una maledizione anche
in questa sfera
secondo me è meglio non fidarsi e quindi
che faccio la devo lasciare qua sopra
ok non posso neanche spostarla non posso
avvicinarmi
aspettiamo e vediamo che succede voi
cosa ne pensate
secondo voi è pericolosa anche questa
sfera forse non vuole toccare la nuova
spesa
che cos'è questo rumore non vi conviene
barbie arabi qualcosa fuori in giardino
che cosa sta succedendo fuori in
giardino
penso che sia colpa di quella sfera si
si sta arrabbiando che cosa devo fare
allora forse devo per forza prendere la
nuova sfera altrimenti succederà
qualcosa in casa o fuori da casa meglio
di no altrimenti chissà in che cosa ti
trasforma con la nuova sfera canali
streaming estremi rimedi per rio
crederti mie care al pettine
cos'è quella luce lì qualcosa
vado io a controllare in tu rimani qua e
pericoloso io vado a controllare vedo se
c'è qualcosa là fuori
prima di qua e controlla la sfera ok ok
stai attenta però è
che cos'è guarda
un biglietto
ai anita trovo dai preti cordoglio
chi è adesso sì chi è
quanto ci piace ad aprire una porta
[Musica]
cos'è quello albè buonasera buongiorno
come posso aiutarla chi sei
domenica mattina la fatina chi sei
o meglio cosa sei la tua sfera e luca è
lasciato con la sfera qui la luce
proveniva da questo biglietto vediamo
cosa c'è scritto ma guarda io non so di
che cosa stai parlando
non lo so proprio che non si dica fatto
non so chi sei tu ma io non hai visto
effettivamente una sfera
sì c'era una sfera 127 sì una sera c'era
chi dice che non stai di corretto
parlando ma tu che cosa 66 una fata e
cruda the phikis figlia con queste hai
una mucca è tardare richiesta che fanno
una fata ora vi metto video dove la
mattina di domani
aspetta aspetta aspetta allora visto che
sei una fata forse ci può aiutare
in pratica la mia ragazza ha toccato
questa sfera e all'improvviso ne sono
uscite le ali e si è trasformato il
fatah
magari ci può aiutare a parlare tornare
com'era prima che crei pensi dimmi solo
dove la fatina e dove la ea sono solo
quattro ore
se il tuo fidanzato vorrei salpare la
nuova sfera dovrai toccare o no forse
vitale in pericolo è meglio che torno
subito da vitale non ti arrabbiare un
tiro gare aspetta aspetta aspetta
riguarda solo un'altra domanda da farti
e non riguarda la sfera è solo una
domanda che ho fin da quando ero bambino
non riesco proprio a togliermela dalla
testa questa domanda la fatina dei denti
v cosa se ne fa dei denti che raccoglie
la cifra una collana
non lo so magari fa delle dentiere e poi
magari deciso di venderla magari vivono
le collanine l'uso che fa aspetta
aspetta troppo scura un'altra domanda
un'altra domanda per favore non mi
lascia altra scelta per la curiosità che
ha lottato tutto questo è piaciuto
questo impedito vista in vita
[Musica]
un po di stile per adesso ecco la sfera
che avevo lasciato mio piccolino
l'aspettiamo stato vedi la partita
chi ne serve per la7 che strisce de qua
sono partite trucchi essere rispettati
di trovarmi qui sei tu la fota della
sfera si sono propri della sorte per me
vieterei dico dell'oste ti senti tu sei
isole che cosa mi fatto dove l'ha
ripreso preoccupare di vita e ha detto
che come una enti l'azione sfera di
cristallo che sono venuto a portarti
persona ho dovuto far sparire in vita
non ti preoccupare non volo riapparire
detto chiama riattiverà e brigati però
perché non ho molta tutti ma cosa
succede ros e tocco la nuova sfera un
ultimo sfera mi ha trasformato in
pattino concorsuali
quindi se tocco questa sfera che cosa
succederà sentite il cubano non va bene
tocca la sfera e con agricoltori ritmo
fidanzato
[Musica]
ehi